I'm very proud of you
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hot box and I'm Evan Britt and I'm
Mike Tyson like we got the champion here
thank you fellas thank you fellas for
having me chance ah [ __ ] well tell me
what was that like growing up in
Brownsville I don't know wow it was it
was it was you know it was uh it was it
was the 80s it was first it was the 70s
and then it was the eighties it was like
you know survival you know it was it was
rougher I didn't support you know
everybody's poor but it was like you
know it was the haves and have-nots some
people had it I was you know I was
fortunate my mom's a working mom and she
you know try to keep me fresh and and
there was those who was trying to take
the palmers or whatever else and it was
like you nice to go to bed pool and my
sneakers took him from me and I remember
leaving my I'm not as I landed talents
pool they took my sneakers from the pool
and no yeah that's so awesome and you
knew fat rustling and stuff I was like
rubber rustle actually he used to
babysit me well yeah listen honesty
rusty I'm on Atlantic between what was
the Rockaway insider so I lived up there
I used to live in a nice breakfast treat
for Mom
Atlantic tiles and that's where my whole
life him is syste my whole life I know
something with you know they used to
babysit me as a kid you know Johnny may
assist you I knew my whole life my mom
was great woman she's got a lot for the
building you know my whole life I know
I'm there mmm that why my whole life I
knew this guy and not know this guy he
knew that guy shout-out to Rusty letting
towers and also always a nice person get
the flower esta used to used to be
flower back of the day was always a nice
man well did you guys know each other
growing out no one'd Aaron Baughman
never know Mike I left already
hmm and I can't charlie you know how was
your 78 yeah he was his name when I
really left I was locked up at 78 I got
locked up and I stayed in the system
yeah but you were legend so you was in
the you know your name always ranked
battles where you came back to the hood
everybody was like you know again we was
hat because we from Brownsville so it
was always like we was the read a dirty
part you know I mean you like the dirty
dudes at Brooklyn so they invited my way
from Browns everything you watch that
guy yeah why
oh they're beat the [ __ ] out of you can
get you kick you out of something then
one Brownsville guys around was around
so Mike being from Brownsville and being
successful it was uh it gave us a lot of
hope there was no hope until then you
see Mike and you're like wow it could be
something I was one of those guys always
in the corner had makuu always snatching
chains picking pockets breaking in cribs
I was just one of those kids since I was
11 years old that's why was I thought
that my destiny I was glad I like the
rest of my friends that's all we know is
robbing people sticking people up
robbing your mother's boyfriends and
stuff like that this is all we knew
robbing people we're oblems if they're
not your friend everybody else is a
victim
mmm you know I mean that that we got
their prey so you'll go till you learn
how to fight early yeah yeah I had a
fight that's one thing we did I thought
helping was to Porto for guns so you had
to know how to fight Wow everybody box
you know and play it Plus play fight him
was a big thing you know slap box in it
so it's like everybody in Browns looking
fight if you girls everybody you haven't
you have to have a listen this is what
might form I expect perspective if
somebody knew that you're prepared
you're prepared to kill them you had all
the respect in the world I'll surely had
some bodies or something isn't that
crazy if you kill some people you have
respect yeah everything was fear-based
pounds of fear base I was always afraid
that's why I brought my life to the ring
and everything my mind would everybody
was afraid to [ __ ] listen the [ __ ]
that audience were afraid yeah you know
they were afraid you know I had that
image that ever and I just it would ruin
my life fear ruin my life hmm you know I
said you know a lot of people say you
know from when you come from the Vale
man you suffer from PTSD right that's
just a fact yeah yeah because you grow
up from early age knowing you go on the
bus you know miss Amanda try take your
bus bus after school so he could wait
you sneak [ __ ] you facts I tell people I
tell that to my wife and she be bugging
I'll be like oh you know hmm
I grew up worried about get raped and
[ __ ] you know I mean it was rapist and I
remember the a guardian angel had to
come to the hood yeah you had to worry
about getting [ __ ] realtalk as a boy
getting raped I was a big thing like you
know I had a Dharma's out in the hood
yeah he was rude you know like it was
legends that you don't even read you
know people that did [ __ ] like that so
it was always wild so growing up like
that you don't take no shape I mean you
get I start I carry it now like
I have to be careful with my temper mmm
because you know sometimes I I can snap
because I live that you know me I live
it it's hard to let that go it's not
even that I can let it go it's Who I am
right I was born until I was born at
Brown December 4th 1971 and although
I've been far removed from it living in
Florida I still carried uh you know the
feelings of love don't don't [ __ ] with
me I'll have to show you you I mean
don't make me show you cuz I will you
found me yeah yeah I always um that's
funny that you said that I'm tripping
that this guy said because I don't want
my kids to know who I am
isn't that something oh my life my kids
are gone I'm gone but I don't want them
to know who I really am
you know I don't want them to know well
that's that's deep like my said you grow
up worried about going to take out the
garbage or going to get the newspaper
and you can't rape then you will you
know at an early age that's something
you learn be careful
so now as you grow older you like okay
now you go to jail that's a whole nother
part of Brownsville because it was like
the rites of passage you know until you
go to jail you have it you know I'm
saying you're not a fish not you're not
mean you're not a real one yeah pretty
much
I mean if you're in that life if you're
on the corner on the time snatchin
change picking pockets and stuff and
listen when I went when I first got
locked up I was 12 years old I was so
scared
and then because when I first was late
at night so I went upstairs I went to
myself and they closed the door and then
it was daytime I had to go to the I had
to go to the [ __ ] will you go when
you have to eat I had to go to breakfast
or whatever all the inmates eat
breakfast right so when I go to when I
go to the chow hall I go to the char I
see all my [ __ ] friends I'm scared
too definitely I go to the childhood I
see all my [ __ ] friends now I'm a
[ __ ]
god nobody better [ __ ] with me hmm
and then so I love being there I've been
every time I came back I got locked up I
love being and sparks all my friends
were there you know being Linda oh and
every time I was locked up then I went
upstate all my friends are there
nobody's gonna touch them no nothing's
gonna happen to me and so that became my
home being an institution that became
institutionalized my pop started prison
I passed my step I was reading he died
at Mercy upstate amasi and it was like I
remember him Barney I remember going to
visit him and write kiss it was like 80
88 and if help going the rack if getting
on the buff that right get in the rack
of his out who's crazy
you know getting the Rockets out of this
hell those crazies transients and then I
remember seeing uh wheezing hesitation
one was crazy and I was I was in Rikers
Island and I knew that it was gonna be a
place where I would eventually because I
knew people was dead and I'm saying I
was acting who did he see my pops on
some some serious stuff like y'all stop
playing it's on a game like he like
Shannon your mom's is telling me you
doing this she doing that and you know
you don't want to be here
and he's a big man strong man and he had
tears run down his eye he said you don't
want to be here this ain't what you
think the same the same you know I'm
saying but at that point my life had
made a turn on you I mean I grew up you
know you know although I lived in
Brownsville I live up the hill you know
that I was always nice after Hill it was
nice and then we moved down the hill I
lived up the hill and then [ __ ] got bad
and all went down that's what happened
to me I went down to come up he's gone
you went down everywhere you went down
there boy you don't know what's down
that hill [ __ ] another level another
level but how
the love of ocean Hill brownfield is
beautiful were you going down that hill
whoa they did it pop it up the hill
though you but down the hill the
monsters you know whoo you can't believe
people like that exist you can't believe
people like that exist yeah well when I
move down the hill you know me life was
different and then I was getting into
like little [ __ ] and then my pops want
to see him I'm all just like I got a
little trouble here and there my pop my
mom's took me to see me but I never seen
him cry you know I mean he cried he was
a big dude big like you yeah dogs games
my stepdad he raised me and he read he
had red eyes naturally it was crazy he
cried and he said you don't want to be
here
and I felt like he was like he was
dissing me I felt like he was saying I
wasn't built like I couldn't take it on
history course oh yeah and I was
rebellious like [ __ ] that you're gonna
see imma making it exciting heard all
the stories get your knife through and
looking back it shows my ignorance it
shows that I was in such a state of
ignorance living in that hood but all I
knew was what I was going to eventually
be dying in prison all my friends was
doing what acts about this person and
the follow his footsteps and he went
down to hell I went down to hell we got
evicted from Atlantic Towers we got
evicted me and my mom and and at that
point we lived all over Brooklyn and I
found story city and I found Jimmy
O'Farrell and that was the change in my
life you know getting into boxing was I
was nothing I mean it gave me a life it
gave me an opportunity to travel the
world and you know I eventually met
Teddy Atlas hmm who he had grew up with
and trained with so it was like it was
ironic and I met Michael Mike Marley and
he was such a he's my first you know
management guy found me he was like you
know Mike Marley very well is it was
crazy because Mike work work no no
listen I was watching from a blue Yuma I
was watching something on YouTube and
inside
Alicia it was almost like a documentary
about you and I showed you with Mike
Marley and all that you had dreadlocks
and you were so thin yeah you look
su-yong how did you come to boxing [ __ ]
what made you want in and I way you know
I love grub love it Muhammad Ali as a
kale you've seen him on TV and my dad
used to watch boxing my stepdad but then
Mike blew up at 86 87 was taken off an
HBO fight Spurs you know mmm and I was
we had got anything
yeah we had got evicted from the towers
and I used to come back to the towers
though you know the visit and it was the
whole I knew I had lived this his birth
and I had moved down the hill and moved
back you know so I used to go to buddy's
house today Ryan Lindsay and his dad
bought us some clothes but I saw from
that Mike was fighting all the time on
TV and I was like are you from
Brownsville I hate to fight three four
times a year and chant and I was alive
so it was like yeah if somebody from
Brownsville could make it you know make
getting boxing whoever thought me cuz I
was only child growing up no I was
picked on and [ __ ] living in the hood
episode we gonna ditch you so but I had
to fight and I think that was all good
for me cuz I've always had to stand up
for myself not having no brothers no
sisters being an only child and then
living in the streets I had to be tough
for myself so but mike is very
influential man every time I see him I
be acting like a little kid he's knows
that I've been talking about your mic
right yo I mean that last time I seen
Craig Boogie Vegas and [ __ ] I'll be
happy to see him because the connection
is like so many different things you
know I mean rusty who he you know grew
up what it knew who babysitting me as a
kid what my mom would be like hey rusty
watched my baby and I mean it's just so
many different things Teddy Atlas
I fought my first fight July 24th 1992
at the tire front tires right front tuck
it what is it Friar Tuck yeah they knew
your statement you're wet Catskills so
there were so many different things but
of course Mike is a different fight I
mean I was a boxer
I was slick with the dress you know but
uh you know just to be from Brooklyn is
to be like browser I was like medium job
mmm that was my goal so you know what's
your champ thank you know what it's like
being for Brownsville and being from
Browns do you feel like nothing but you
still proud isn't that weird how did
that happen I was telling my boyfriend
money that still proud I was telling my
boyfriend money I said you know he said
son I said no you understand we from a
village this is best our Bushwick
Canarsie East Flatbush Flatbush you know
I'm saying
and it's Brownsville we still we we did
they used to connect to we the dirty
people with a dirty do so we stick
together like you know yeah we different
you know man we just you know we
different it cause the villains the
brown villians
kill each other on sight but one day out
of town they they're together as we
stick together isn't that weird but one
soon as soon as we're back in Branson
[ __ ] imma blow your brains out in that
way that's who we are
nobody kill you but me we gonna kill him
yeah you're not [ __ ] with another
Browns would do yeah we stick together
I'm gonna kill them oh my well it's
amazing how you know until you found
boxing and then saw Mike and understood
that he was from the same place you were
you didn't really see a way out but Mike
was like a roadmap to get out of there
got something bigger I followed it ie he
went down a hill you got with Teddy
alleys I got with Teddy I
he's new Mike Marley I know I stayed in
the head of I stayed in that building I
thought it was condemned and then we
stayed there winners was condemned and
we had to leave but the people had to
fix the building up four people can live
in there now so then we went to the
[ __ ] monster [ __ ] people with no
souls in a browser like soulless people
who are kind soul if kind people wasn't
that family I don't make no sense but
that's what it is she ended what would
it boxing mean to you as you Scott on
your career and you started fighting
from that first fight at friar Tuck's
and the Catskills and you know I've
heard Mike talk a lot about his boxing
career and he has a big perspective on
you know the good and the bad yeah and
what did it mean to you to be following
in those footsteps and carving your own
path you know it was happening so fast
happening I was literally trying I was
homeless man I used to spend nicest re
City boxing gym thanks to Jimmy O son
jobs he let me sleep at his house
sometimes I sleep in the jumpy you know
I just sleep on the train the D train a
train well you know I sleep a friend's
house family members when I could you
know mean but those those times in my
life they they were they were setting me
up for my future you know Sam and by the
time I got in the box and it happened so
quick I went from like you know how he
had like 33 amateur fights something
like that I was on the USA team like
he's 92 you know Mike Tyson's a
superstar I'm like okay and I'm just
Mike I mean Mike Marley he was the best
hype man believed in me when I wasn't
you know he was throwing me in D and I
was like oh [ __ ] you know he was just
happening so fast at all I look back and
I said damn the money started coming in
I met Mark Roberts shout out to Mark
Roberts he uh he did a lot for my career
early and then uh afterwards it just
thought going crazy I wasn't really
prepared cuz I had really jumped out of
like my New York situation to Jersey man
in Jersey it was like okay this who you
are this what you're gonna do you're
gonna follow the steps of Mike Tyson so
I started knocking dudes out mmm I had
like my first year I had like ten first
try knocked out 11 first round knockout
so they were like the next Mike Tyson
he's from browser unless like Mike Tyson
mom applies so he's got the same train
as Mike Tyson so it was great marketing
you fell me and and the gym teddy was
working me he had Mia doing a lot of
sparring and it was you know it was a
lot to learn
first heavyweight championship in 97 yes
brother
and then 98 yes brother no no I wanted
to get in on 2006 2006 2007 yeah how did
that feel
yeah I'll do it fair - Mike was in a
while it was good Mike was around
everybody else key it was good it was
good times but I I had lost I had lost
two down Wolf's on HBO I got in either
the heavyweights
and I was like 25 or no and after that
everybody walked away from me like the
whole the whole bottom fell out you know
and then uh I remember like trying to
get my [ __ ] back together and I wanna
you know George Foreman picking me out
of like a school fighters like you know
his look at this guy be easy win
after a couple wins you know you need a
quick fight and um you know I want to
give the decision against him and it was
like damn but all doing that time and I
was in a bad place my mom's was still on
drugs she wanted to have a heart attack
on my birthday - I actually drug
overdose on my birthday December 4th I
was in a bad place so eventually it
caught up to me but I think I made out I
made I don't care considering that where
I was at and where I'm at now
beautiful kids you beautiful wife you
know I'm a shout out to my wife Alana
and my three beautiful children but you
know it's been it's been a it's been a
roller coaster to be honest I don't mean
them to our people but yesterday I said
I said it this morning I think i'ma say
the rest of my life you know to my wife
and say baby I'm really grateful to be
in your life and you love me to be in
your life because um how did this happy
and I say to myself how did I get here
who was Mike Tyson how did I create this
monster or this whatever it was
something that people love I don't know
a fan I come whatever it
how's that happen who is that guy you
know that can inspire people you know
they don't know sometimes this guy
leaves his mind he thinks about
covenants of this that's insane
sometimes but still the infant till he
can influence people and he inspires
people that's what we do here arts you
know that's why I wanted to come kick it
with y'all yeah I wanted to look you in
the face cuz you know cuz I go through
it you feel me
yeah and as a man my wife is she part of
me you don't mean like I told my wife
I'm open candid about it I mean like
I've suffered from you know depression
and face to cannabis I changed my life
I'm just watchin three pounds Wow I was
suicidal for years you know and then a
friend of mine was like your champ
you're good too you gotta go hard but
the alcohol bro you know fill me yeah
and I'm eight years clean alcohol but I
miss I miss smoking cannabis and it's
changed my life man
shoutout to you on what you're doing
thank you Sam listen man you applying in
you're a great man and like so many ways
because I've been fortunate to be saved
by the plant you fell me yes understand
and I've turned other fighters and I'm
not gonna blow the body up but I've
tried other fighters on to the plant and
they say damn champ thank you you know
they appreciate me I lost 168 pounds so
cannabis yeah I got back to shape I want
ten fight straight before you know I
mean you're taking another I'm taking a
hiatus I'm back now champ I'm in the gym
I go to the gym now real talk
I go to the gym and I'm 48 years old I
go to the gym nice party I don't want to
blow nobody up cuz yummy I don't want to
put nobody out there cuz you know me I'm
a nice guy but if somebody gives me my
skin I'm gonna keep your funky I'm gonna
tell you you is I'm gonna come back and
tell you but I'll be working with these
do the young boys right getting ready
for a big face and I'll be beating a ass
I'm an old dude I'm an old academy champ
I'll be beating the ass and I'd be
saying to myself like I feel like you
know George Foreman like you know me I'd
be like yo Shannon come back get money
you know I'm saying but then I'd be like
chill chance coach and I'll be like
chill chill
weird that it's to talk about that cause
you started that yes brother
and I think it was you know through your
dealings with depression and you know
suicidal thoughts you know I dealt with
that my whole life is well known and so
you created this positive affirmations
yeah well we all are aren't we at some
time at some point you know even
sometimes when it's sometimes I think
I'm high a mighty sometimes you know I
get that feeling some but I think I'm
better than some and then my conscious
you still think that I know that's who
we are that's where we came from
ridership I'll be like yo I'm a piece of
[ __ ] I'd be saying that to myself and it
wasn't for my wife Ilana what did you
call like if you've been through the war
you got yeah that's the I know I gotta
tell people don't play with much money I
got famous for being from brothers how
dare you piece of lousy gutters should
treat that person like that as well be
telling people
being from that that keeps you in check
to being some grounds to check you
you're the bottom of the people you're
the bottom of humanity in New York and
we flew from Brownsville brows that
keeps you just being from they've
checked you because we come around baby
whispering yeah he's violence I went on
for violence and robbery and all that
stuff that these in criminal activity we
can fight though like real talk like
Mike fight everybody has to know the
fight because we cut everybody ain't got
no guns you could fight in Brownsville
you'd be on picking everything you
should see fights in 80s and not have
anybody have sons there anybody got
guards I think the skills is dropping a
little bit of browser you shout out to
Brownsville you're brown real toy shout
out demands a good job but you know what
chant and that's another thing I talked
to you I seen but we gonna open up a
Brownsville the Browns of boxing Academy
you got three former heavyweight
champions from the same neighborhood
Mike Tyson Riddick Bowe with Shannon
Briggs this is never wrong
come on we gonna do it the boxing
Academy know me everything's going to
school no he lived over to my
grandmother lived in noble joy he lived
upstairs from us do you understand the
connection he lived upstairs for me he
lived around the corner from me when he
moved down and boy I move down the
Marcus Garvey you feel what I'm saying
you got to understand this ain't no days
walking business and boy and Marcus
Garvey Omar listen cuz if you live in
Amboy know what separates Marcus Garvey
and Amboy a big park yes one Street over
Hopkinson high tops
tom is boiling now I seen you in the
park yeah you came at the park everybody
was sure I was too but I had to see you
you know look at what was he doing he
was coming to
Nirvana son
[Music]
I was like oh [ __ ]
you mean listen like I said no I guess
didn't know to do I thought I knew I
knew I had to come back to Hooker and
then no anything else you know I was up
there living the life and stuff but my
heart my soul was D I had to go there
huh you know I had this cozy and shine I
had to let those people know look at me
now uh-huh
you know why I say he be champ because
I'll be setting myself like I don't know
if I could survive this [ __ ] might went
through I'm gonna keep it funky like I
mean he keep me alive too because when I
look at my life inch and I look at my
life I'd be like sure out you know me
I'll be like chill out
you're me Mike Tyson had it works bro
you know because if I had a hundred
million when I was 20 years old I've
been dead you feel me if I had a hundred
million that thirty out of it down I was
dead I came back my body would have been
disintegrated like dantos got me or some
[ __ ] you fell out of bed finish I mean
finito when I was young with money now
and get God that you know I never try
cocaine I never tried heroin you know
I'm saying I was always afraid I mean so
that's another thing that thing kept me
you know I mean I used to drink like a
sailor though your mom from 13 you
started with forties you know forties
and [ __ ] now and then you gotta stop I
got asthma hmm you know I never smoked I
stayed away from cannabis and Travis 40
years old eyes I'm 48 I didn't start
smoking tongs 40 how do you feel the
cannabis affects your asthma does it
travelers in the head
as metamers the day I started smoking
yeah don't sell the drugs my one since I
haven't had an asthma attack I haven't
picked up of course prednisone I haven't
picked up any type of steroids for
asthma told us something hmm
you know I'm coming I was a sex addict a
drug addict and stuff I did the toll I
stopped I stopped [ __ ] people up this
two years till now I stopped doing them
cocaine and stop [ __ ] God oh it's
cold and that gives me give me God
what is it it's DMT oh okay I want a
smoke do we I'm scared ya know we all
love this we all worth you that's what
it did it takes away your fear takes
away your fear brother you can't wait to
die I'm always afraid you never back in
the days when you just like you should
know it do and then like he's like smoke
saw and I saw happy that you see and me
be crazy yeah I remember that he never
come back yeah that's what doesn't they
did that's what that was right remember
in the hood back in the days number
Kurtis with the stills don't know if
that hot but so he was a good do I loved
nothing like hurt us he was good I loved
her so I'm on the court Kurtis I used to
solid the trees downtown remember all in
the wheelchair
y'all know in the wheelchair
oh I remember crippled Mike in those
guys and Browns to see these guys
probably dead by the time you came on
the sing you're such a young boy you
think your oldest if you think you
better oh yes a baby when I box champ
they can't [ __ ] with me this is what
because my mind is still in Brownsville
do you think if that's the reason yeah I
can't as PTSD I ain't take the toll you
like the toll might show me out too much
girl me I don't know who knows in my to
you I might make you words might get
more conscious might give him more
knowledge
then you freaking out of everything cuz
you know a lot now maybe it's better you
don't do that oh yeah big stuff that it
gives you so much perspective it grow
you have to grow up real quick you know
I think Riddick the other day how they
doing man life prepared this for death
yeah you're gonna do something for the
hood champ hood
we got three heavyweight champions that
came from a neighborhood that's not even
two miles big and you got three
heavyweight chambers that never before
been done in history of the world I came
with this ideas concept 10-15 years ago
and I believe to this day that we'd be
if this in over a half a billion dollars
have to be generated from boxing just
from Brownsville alone no it's not a
billion then you got Danny Jacobs Curtis
Stevens any Mustafa Muhammad you feel me
sad Judah so many great fighters from
Brownsville you know I'm saying we can
imagine this it's like going to looking
for racehorses you go I'm gonna go to
this country or whatever jockeys you
want to fight out you want a heavyweight
champions the kind of place there's a
lot of great athletes a lot of great
fighters the it can't beat the streets
that's what we want and that's what this
is where I come to the since you know
the street undefeated you know if you
want to start a life or do anything the
streets you gonna lose time to feed it
there's no hotel know anybody ever beat
the street you know let's they stopped
your shout out shout out to kill the
calf and og nuke descent tell you God
give them my love - oh gee no I Love You
Man no the cab love you you know I'm a
new home you know that yeah big new do
we
oh man that's listen man staying home -
from Lincoln's home shoutout to stinky
home did you know famous yeah no I see
Fame another day I see flame I went to I
went to school with his brother Malik
was in my class you should sit next to
me and we should get in trouble all the
time
mo people I talk to Billie dance
shoutout to Billie man shut up supreme
magnetic yeah I used to look up to the
gods and I'm saying all of this
let me did a lot for me I'm gonna keep
it real flat bullet enough that was that
grouping them till we got evicted so we
stayed there now where's this place for
green you know being I met all those
guys I mean back then we were all going
I was in 101 off poor level you're
staying with somebody back in the day we
all went right in that little complex it
was a day kiss and then all those guys I
met them in the day before we started
selling drugs are going to sports are
doing all that stuff
we just we s I wasn't that little school
together we were like funny six years
old kids this is Pete games me spike
there's a common in hospital Michael Joe
and that Michael - I was bored come here
Eddie Murphy
Spike Lee me you know the devil is right
across the park from there
yeah watching them [ __ ] that big part of
my life is to know why I'm appalled yeah
Parks Louis Hayward
yeah let's go chat yeah we always been
evicted we had no place to go we were
homeless so we stayed and so I know
these guys that became vicious mean drug
device to me in preschool with them and
stuff
crazy it was the last time you guys went
back to Brownsville this knows I'm
Brandon not too long ago no last year
that's it but it was this [ __ ] like I'm
gonna won't get months ago you know it's
like a month or three months four months
ago
I always listen something's weird about
Brownsville I always have to go to cuz
it's like I've lost something or
something's missing or something's wrong
[ __ ] money I could be a self a friend
to me why am I here with these [ __ ]
man because I'm recharged
yeah no one else's because I'm one of
them
oh my life I'm trying to get away from
these I can't figure why I keep coming
back I should be able to self a friend
that should be with a bunch of no but no
people but then again I'm wonder why my
rounding I can't trust them they're
dangerous I was just home I in mine
and I called new new kidney and he was
like yo come to the barbershop and then
the next day my little bro creme Ram
Quran was like come home jab now we say
your man cuz is the veil look you got
going to reset you in charge I realize
it's what's keeping me at my work it's
what kept me alive for a long time
because you don't really want to go
there's no hatchet and I'm right here
before your time you really don't want
to go back to see why you do what you do
so you don't end up back you phony I
think it cuz I say I gonna see my boys
turn Arland I think I form five license
and
knowing it is just it shut off the time
but it's gotta go yeah it's gotta see
this you know cuz I mean my mother when
I was 10 Elvis they all my part of my
life and listen this this lady I'm Joan
River raid and they were doing a
documentary on Joan Rivers and it was
her eating one of these guys that she
knew forever right and he was a junkie
something was wrong so he didn't come
around if something my cigar santahat
but he was he was an addict and a bus
was happier he was gonna leave the
advocates of trouble but it bothers hell
because um you don't have the person
that you remember when I'm gonna kill me
you remember one such as I suppose of my
mom when they killed that but I have a
little shoot don't have that person
nobody no more there's nobody around say
hey yo remember when I keep a guy my
bunk got bugs I keep him with me some
Browns like world with him but I keep
him with me and stuff because I need
somebody do man i'ma win no I don't know
that's true when you don't have somebody
like that around you you're lost
who are you think about it that's always
keep somebody from such-and-such did
that member this and that something
happened in the seventies and she was
really hurt because now we don't have
nobody
yo remember them when you don't have
somebody like that around where are you
at Oh 77 I was beautiful I was robbing
stores at all we couldn't wait keep food
it broke this man food I was in I was in
- possible the first to speak with this
man I was in that Parkway from Marcus
Garvey at a big parking but he had knows
before but yet you know that Christmas
tree Christmas tree yeah I was in
persisted
hanging out actually right across the
street right smoking weed right and the
right for a neighbor else's [ __ ] that
[ __ ] we're gonna rob
understand that everybody was happy and
I was 11 years old and so I went robbing
places - it was happy I was on a stupid
market I was on a stupor city park my
neighborhood his name was chilly one man
car my life I was 11 years old then and
I knew that we was coming to rob but
some of my old life was criminal I was
born in criminal my whole life was
criminal
we just was we just in that neighborhood
no no listen if he was born in Beverly
Hills you probably been a different
person chap yeah the person that I am
now would you party it's all about
environment you found me the environment
we was in was you know it was Rob's all
about survival survival watching people
getting killed you out your friends get
killed
you watching your friends kill people
you're watching your friends to your
other friends whoo wow that's something
isn't that something you watching your
friend kill another friend of yours you
know what that's like huh whoo he
getting hit with some browsers guys man
we know we don't know too much happy
stuff doing [ __ ] keep somebody getting
shabby you don't like it's cool you know
it's just weird our lifestyle the way
that we think but we survive and it's
that's the good news channe come on
touch it no let's go chat we survive
that's the good news
that's cool that's cool champ is about
draw me I don't know anybody stronger
than people from Browns I have so much
respect for them yeah me too so much
respect for them
I don't never think I'm better than them
because I'm I may be more successful it
made me more money than I know I'm not
tough enough I know that trust me
I know I survived yes by the grace of
God no I'm not toughening those people
I'm not tougher than my father and my
mother I was safe by the grace of God
Sam's my grad yeah
yeah you guys should you guys should
build a facility very movie yeah I'm
looking at spot I'll pick an avenue you
know I mean the spot right now and I
talked to his brother-in-law body we
know we're honest Scouts my mom my
manager my brother my man that just got
hurt he's behind a project he's he's a
quarterback yeah happened before we died
Yeah right now now are we doing it right
now it's gonna be the Brownsville boxing
Academy they're gonna come in and see
Mike Tyson on the wall Riddick Bowe
Shannon Briggs all the gray all our
grades and they're gonna be inspired
that's what we're gonna do it ain't just
boxing you might want to be a referee
you might want to be a timekeeper a
judge a manager promoter we're gonna
give classes and seminars because we
have generated over if not over a
billion dollars from this small
neighborhood into the boxing industry
guess what something's in the water in
Brownsville something's in the water we
can fight
we're not playing let us make money yeah
we could do a we could shoot basketball
we could be scientists
we could build rockets we work is you
know how to work we know how to get it
cuz we hungry yeah we hungry people
would fill me and they always discus
lies put us last we the Brownsville
people you dirty so guess what we that
keep us hungry we always made no
interested about brothers a place that
has such a bad reputation that people
are so proud to be from it's not crazy
yeah never will but like Mike said it
best we'll kill each other but if you
out of town are you from Brownsville and
somebody say something out of character
to you we aren't like walls blow your
[ __ ] brains out we gonna fight a
fight ahead up
like God word up we get back the hook
baby it's gonna be a fight dude I mean
you know another level is killing but we
get back and I'm definitely gonna be
gonna shoot a fair when we get back but
uh you out of town and somebody from
Brownsville you know name we going we're
gonna ride on you together cuz we were
but we got people like myself we didn't
we the most loving people in the world
look at Mike Tyson man come on come on
you ever see talked to Riddick Bowe hey
bugs can be a god
I don't know about really Shannon Briggs
though I don't know but look at what
could I have to go to the be who I am
you know you think about that as a
person what a person have to go to the
be who they are what they appear to be
yeah Wow
I think box and true like the punches we
took to the head you know I'm saying a
company with the survival that we had to
have you know you know the damage you
know but I think that a company with you
know the life upbringing it takes a toll
you know guys like me and Michael had it
rough for me and I mean nothing
and I don't compare it but if someone
else would look at it like you know
that's a damn shame
but I'll still fight you feel my
suffering from depression to this day
but I'm blessed to have a phenomenal
wife man you know like Mike you know I
him often speak about his wife and how
she is a savior I'm in the same position
champ yeah my wife what was that for
Alana I wouldn't be this is what I
understand that's interested she said
wouldn't be alive that sense you should
know what I found out about myself
because I'm always studying myself I
found out that I'm married because I've
been married three times and something
and I'm now what 54 53 whatever and I
get married because I'm not be somebody
because I can't live with myself you
know that means I can't live like PSD
whatever you said it I can't I can't
live on my thoughts no that's real talk
manga this shows not about children I'm
just saying
I'm saying chill chant cuz you [ __ ]
with me hurt you know me that's why my
wife is what's hold me now because like
yo man I'm a [ __ ] nut you made me a
little good guy everybody who knows me
knows I'm harmless and it says whereas
I'm not a troublemaker
I'm never gonna you know yeah I like
that phone number jokester you know
media even in my box you can see my
trolling like let's go when all the
fighters I love this guy funny and I'm
entertained in that sense but I also
suffer from people's self-esteem facts
you know no and then my wife has been
the person who who has stuck by me with
no one else has I've had family you feel
me and said I have relatives my you know
I have family but I want no mom no dad
no brothers and sisters and my wife is
mine it's my life my kids you feel me so
she's been the person that stuck by me
when nobody else Rob you know I've done
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] you feel me
but she still was like yo she rolled
with me when no Brad broke yeah you know
it came back in the ring when everybody
doubted me winning the title the first
time the second time coming back now
fighting still at 48 years old and I go
to the gym and she see me beat [ __ ] out
of people and she like damn I but she
used to it so it's not like a big thing
but she like you know she's supportive
of me so at 48 I think I'm gonna come
back to hurt a couple people champ hey
let me tell you something about me and
my wife's relationship okay um I come
I'd like stress this up know I love my
wife so much I believe because I'm
without my wife from when I don't have
my wife in my life um I am
what am I have a big [ __ ] hole never
be filled
give it all sex drugs let me keep it
coming come on [ __ ] get her man
my wife my wife from fills that hole you
know it took that whole thank you that's
what my wife does she fills that hole
cuz without my wife um um I can't we
feel bad than that you name being alone
and that's the biggest thing for me like
me and alone was the hardest thing for
me cuz like money came you know I mean
not to his level the money came I was
always making money out there and you
feel I was always fortunate to be a
turtle it enough to get his business
deals and you know make the movie shaky
I mean Wall Street different things but
you know yeah we're afraid of being
alone but still be around a thousand
people were still alone I got everybody
y'all well the good news was first I
went broke but then I thought they could
pray but not enough to fort afford an
entourage anymore so I got over there
three chains I started focusing more on
feed knob and stop taking my boys on the
road and you know having fun and all
that shaking at me so when I did that I
got more focus on that all my money just
tired up take care you know right in the
case I don't have money for [ __ ] yeah
it's mater let man I don't care about
money it's that no more why finally
anything my wife no she takes care of a
kid that's fine I don't care if I don't
exist it's nothing anyway isn't one to
see them yes blossom yeah you know we
got a deal with life on life its life on
life [ __ ] they got to deal with that
thing I deal with love and all that
crazy stuff um I used to like to see
them have a healthy life yeah I feel
like I thought to myself I was like you
know the only thing I wanna do but all
should never eat done is make my wife
happy so that she can look back if I was
thought Amaro well I think I think for
me and my is for my background from
leaving her well off you know
financially well off so that she doesn't
have to worry because I was my biggest
fear for my wife and my daughters and my
kids to have to rely on a man allows
someone else you feel me so I want to be
able to leave there in position so they
don't ever have to depend or allowing a
man because no one's gonna love them who
knows I'm not to say that but they fear
I'm in fear that some more love miss
Marchant you say that but take this out
who are you who are you what can you do
what can you stop what kind of control
do you believe you have nothing champ
except financially being responsible
like I wasn't in the past I wasn't
responsible because I was irresponsible
because I didn't give a [ __ ] I was I
gotta enjoy myself now cuz I had a whole
lot you speak of that was so deep
women cause everything nothing to the
extent of you but to my level know I was
balling fill me to my level I was
balling it's all what you believe like I
about belief and I was enjoying the
moment but I had this this was just
guilt in like 10 man you got a good girl
champ you buggin you know man then I was
like but [ __ ] that yeah so it was always
to tell the world with with the war
within myself like I was fortunate to
meet my wife yeah right yeah we've been
together 26 years on and on I mean she
stuck by my side so I do well I mean I
work lie to me
I fought Vitali Klitschko in 2010 and in
the first round my left hand in popped
and my joint popped in the first round
and I took a brutal beating for 12 hours
and I mean my [ __ ] was cracking me
right
I ain't quit and I was in the hospital I
was dead it was in the coma um and my
wife was right there the whole time he
fell me and then I came out of that [ __ ]
and I was like everybody again stepped
on me bounced on that pain own this horn
say to about my little people ready
thank you pay for fighting like he says
he took a lot of punishment and said why
don't why do we have a problem
it's not about browns that we got from
where megalomaniac that's what we are
what doesn't meet you we believe that
we're God but we have a low self-esteem
isn't that something
how could that be how does that work out
how's that you know and then after I've
studied all that those are the more
successful people why is that how could
somebody be so successful when the
answer to low self-esteem cuz they're
driven to achieve more yeah I think
that's something I guess it's just
amazing I'm one of those people yeah you
know just how does that work though dude
that doesn't make sense to somebody he
just wouldn't make sense to a scholar
well I you know it wouldn't make sense
to a scholar
yeah but if you understand and you study
the function and the experience of the
soul like for me I've boiled a lot of my
[ __ ] down to i'm never enough for myself
you know no matter what i do how much i
accomplished how much i achieve how much
success i have how many people love me
i'm never enough for myself oh yeah
you know chance and once I hit that I
was like wow and it doesn't matter
because the more I do to be enough the
more it validates that I have to keep
doing [ __ ] to make myself feel like I'm
enough it's like why can't I just be
enough let's go you know what it is man
he survived was champ [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] yeah we can't be [ __ ]
throwing the pity parties that [ __ ] that
is there's a [ __ ] let's go chance that's
how I created that [ __ ] because I was
down on myself it was 403 pounds I was
taking
um depakote seroquel packs who all type
of shock I was fat coming to see my dick
I look down so fat
four three two and a half years and then
I was like yo I'm gonna off myself and
then one one day my home he came to me
cause his name was Jerome called Bahamas
he said champion to try this mmm and all
aside chill chat mind with that you'd
understand mmm I was a daddy for me I
got asthma he was a champ and telling
you and then one day champ he left it at
my crib hmm and I went and I picked it
up and I had dreads
I had just for like 27 years and I don't
know what it was I was in thought and I
took it and I sparked the champ I hit it
I started crying bro well I started
crying bro I started crying and I did
not flash and I seen my whole life and
did I see myself cut up in shape walking
it like being around the world and
people loving me and I was like and I
win the crib and I sat down when the
house is sat on the couch and I dozed
off sitting up I never do that hmm I
woke up in the morning and I just
walking my bathroom champ and I just cut
my hair off without a thought and then I
went out by my pool and it was a half
for the joint left and I smoked the last
of it
and I called my boys wrong I said what
the [ __ ] was that you brought to my crib
he was like yo champ I apologize cuz he
was used to cook no I said no bring some
more hmm and then he brought some treats
to my crib and I started smoking in the
same day I cut my hair I poured the
pills in and in the toilet I stopped
drinking alcohol it's been eight years
champ fill me
smokey trees and then I started saying
let's go champ
cuz I realize nobody gave a [ __ ] nobody
kids and I was by myself and I ain't
believin myself I hated myself I was fat
I was depressed but guess what don't you
orange was gone but I said imma being my
own [ __ ] entourage I'm gonna be my own
cheerleader so I start saying let's go
champ
let's go champ let's go champ you feel
me I was like [ __ ] everybody I'm gonna
get on my feet you feel me and that's
what I did that's why when the
trademarked that [ __ ] cuz I said it's
gonna be my own chill I'm gonna be my
own cheerleader
I'm inspired myself and then it caught
on cuz I start typing myself up every
time I say let's go champ I hear myself
saying yeah my meters start going up I
start getting activated chair yeah I
start getting activated and that's why I
say nobody give a [ __ ] what happened to
us whether we was raped whether we was
beat up
we was left alone all that [ __ ] happened
to me my mom's left me in a car
when I was a little kid she fell asleep
getting shooting heroin and I was almost
dead I could have frostbit you know I'm
saying but nobody give a [ __ ] it's my
life they feel me I could write a book
in them but so what you feel me
I gotta keep moving on feed my kids if I
don't feed them nobody else is the next
man stop it - my wife life he might take
advantage of this shannon briggs wife or
ex girl let me do this his kids know I
got a do not care now I'm alive to leave
them a nest egg where they could be
secure yeah let's go champ
[Music]
let's go I hope you know what nice for
the people name I'll write a check you
know you gotta be who you are you can't
be something for someone else
yeah I'm just happy to be here with
y'all man I'm very proud of you
thank you brother you know when I see
you keep on no this isn't you when I see
you keep succeeding and you you go I'm
proud to be from Brownsville talking I
know what you're going doing laughs
where did my mother she died she died on
my birthday December 1996 mmm when I'm
dead when I'm dead on e mentally I can
wake him sometime I guess you know my
testosterone might be low or something
like then I'm gonna real estate a
depression and I'd be like yeah I'm
[ __ ] so depressed I'd be like [ __ ]
relax what you think Mike Tyson felt
like when he was accused of rape he was
in jail he was a great champion now you
away from his bread not to cut you off I
apologize but I'm just saying you know
that's just sort of something that I
keep in my brain as a reminder when I
cool like champ you buggin relax you
depressed but it could be worse champ
you could be Mike at this point and if I
had to Bret you had I might a truck okay
I might have tried something else my
mother died from that [ __ ] I'm saying my
sister dies I'm in Philly
that's who what [ __ ] you know what you
have any idea who I am
baby you completely you chirp I'm trying
not baby you my mother and father the
sex workers you know the sex workers I
don't get my mother and father a sex
workers my aunts and uncles the sex
workers he measured mean the kids are
sex workers we're never protected and
the people relieve us to protect this is
perfect so my mother father kind of
perverted this perverse to is who we are
you know no [ __ ]
chill out bro you came on my show no you
see yourself huh chill out bro
okay I'm talking about me I'm not
talking about you you talked about us a
lot of young black brown white kids
around the world yellow suffering chat
and that's what let's go chapters about
and that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna make a difference because yo just
like me and you champ
it's millions of others bro and they
don't got a Mike Tyson named Riddick
Bowdoin Shannon Briggs they need a way
out champ we're gonna do what we don't
make the Brownsville box in the county
already with nuke already looking at the
pay less on picking avenue I'm talking
to you
your brother-in-law Hazim he's a great
brother you know Craig boogie we gonna
make this [ __ ] happen chat because the
main about us it's about the women and
children that need a way out of the veil
bro but they need a way out the Ville
bro we can either way out bro you know
um
I'm so happy you're here it's
interesting somebody thinks that I'm
something special and I still have a
different opinion about myself I'm not
gonna go down a show but it's weird you
know somebody some Browns think that I'm
some and me being from Browns that makes
me feel the way that I do in that
strange
Wow yah got ya Wow let's go champ
hmm never ran never will the movie is
coming soon okay
loving brand never will it's the story's
story we mean it's about saving lives at
this point man your story
you fell me you know there's a with the
great right who would ever thought so
what I realized I got you chat we should
Iran sometimes we would have still been
here we would exist we should have ran
something we have 20 pride life is pride
is this too much cry and if you [ __ ]
with that pride yeah we gonna make it a
point to make your example to show you
that I suffered with that you're saying
I was saying I was put into a position
we had to violated me and I had to live
with that as far as not physical
violation but on some Street [ __ ] like
since we disrespect pun anyway with DNA
and I'm like okay you know me what do I
do in this position I know what I and I
know what I'm supposed to do as a father
doesn't work as a man relax chill out
let that [ __ ] go but the Browns reeling
me won't let it
it's like yo when I see this
[ __ ] I mean knock his teeth out
but then I say Shannon you're a fool you
loved around the world people Domeier
you for inspiring them but I tell them
look I'm real you know I don't have any
endorsements I don't get those you know
I endorse my own stuff let's go champ
and it's real be know why because I'm
honest and then ain't for everybody to
see rest in peace Kobe Bryant by the way
you feel me but um I say that to say you
know I'm not the type of person that you
don't mean I'm a real dude
where you gonna get what you get you're
mean with me you feel me but I'm at a
point in my life so different is real
I'm real meaning you see this if the
cameras is on you're gonna see me that's
why I was like chill champ cuz you're
gonna see I wear my heart on my sleeve
you feel me you've seen me in the street
hey champ was sigh hey Shannon what's up
I take pictures everybody a hug
everybody I'm
you know I'm a good guy but if you
violate me and you put if you press me
or you put something against me that
make me show that I gotta be different
I'm a you know I'm a teddy bear but I'm
still a bear
you feel me and then I got a Shawn over
saying why because my roots is
Brownsville and when you said you could
get [ __ ] I understand because that was
a fear my growing up you feel me
in Brownsville that was a fear mine get
raped
[ __ ] like that you feel me so when you
go up like that and you have to get your
sneakers took and you got a fight you
gotta worry about your mother you know
my mom's is on crack you feel me my
friends selling my mother cry this is
the [ __ ] I live you feel me and then you
see your mom's begging in front of
McDonald's for money you see your mother
prostitute and on Coney Island Avenue
pieces and things that I experienced so
when you say that I'm like chill champ
but I feel you this is what the people
need this is what I want you got a champ
this is what you I need to hear so you
if you out there going through that you
understand the great Mike Tyson went
through it Shannon Briggs and many
others went to it pain don't give the
[ __ ] up champ keep going that's what
it's about champ keep going and that's
why I was saying no [ __ ] pity party
for us look at a Shaw we here chillin in
California wanna podcast look at you you
clean shoes like let the people see how
you livin you love me good you clean you
look a fly you got your own we breathe
nobody's doing better than you chat but
deep inside when no one else can see I'm
a savage cuz guys like me and Mike who
have took punches to the head had a
rough life they need to be reminded not
of the Brownsville [ __ ] of the good [ __ ]
you got cuz we don't appreciate [ __ ]
beautiful wife beautiful life beautiful
house we wanna be is not good enough
listen you keep talking and listen you
want to show that he keeps talking we're
and that's very you know listen you like
[ __ ] don't like a different channel
nothing you see little people that die
and we'll create it's not meant for us
to be crazy enough in man this is not
meant to be a sparring for all those
years you don't think it had an effect
on your your chemist your brain
chemistry listen brother I think it made
me better smarter
yes definitely yeah fighting being a
fighter Wow being a fighter one made me
want to know everything about fighting
it's a theory about fighting some of the
greatest um well let me put it this way
some people have the reputation of being
great fighters but which they're not but
they have great fighting theory a theory
was magnificent on fighting that easy
take the radar cell house again I don't
watch ourselves he should take me to
radar cell house teddy was a used to
knowledge Teddy's taking you to radio so
house in 92 before he died
hey we used to watch tapes cuz he wanted
me to learn the history like Mike Davy
one day he said Mike was a student that
he said he loved you he loved and he
loved using and resin you know and I
love teddy yeah me too I never I've
never tried no [ __ ] like [ __ ] kicking
his ass or hitting that he taught me
this is what listen this is how I eat or
imagine what he has to do when he sees
me doing all these fights they said why
this is my [ __ ] work right here and
then he had me afterwards right after
when I'm from Brownsville
but he beat the [ __ ] out of me about it
yeah cuz you had y'all situation you
gonna do like Mike and I'm like mom I'm
my own person I miss you know I'm like
but he was like unbelievable teacher and
father figure to me and that's why when
we split my [ __ ] went crazy but I was
more hurt too because I trusted him so
much
I love them and we split and he you know
was I guess better fan business-wise and
everything moving forward but I was more
hurt because I have nobody my mom's want
died I'm saying I was [ __ ] up I needed
somebody in my life to it and I went off
the deep end
where did you go to split I lost $1 oh
this is so interesting you know be with
custom art oh right I came back then
with custom Island nobody always talked
to me about it's not getting discouraged
it's delete about all the great fighters
and er I'm strong in these guys these
guys are monsters
Benny Leonard monsters these guys I
knocked out in the first fight of the
second or they got knocked out three or
four times and then um somebody um some
chapters kept winning some fights you
know some Club fights but they were
wooden fights and then some champion so
easy um pay there you can get and you
know be somebody and they knock the
champion out and it didn't they're
undefeated for eight years and young son
Barrett they've been knocked at their
first fighter this second for living
knocked up quite a few times and then
they start winning a couple of fights
with some easy fight and then the champ
say hey that's the easy defense right
here let me first and then they knock
the champ out right and didn't know what
happens done defeated for nine to ten
years everybody talking about wild
speaking of wild leaf
belief nothing more flowers and belief
they Sam wild oat the hardest hit in
their history what you think I don't
know probably if he never hit me I don't
know I know this power but listen being
the hardest puncher doesn't mean that I
want to be the best fighter you know how
many people I think is harder than me
and harder than for him but they're not
champion
and I champion harder than enough they
look better than us they got more money
than us but then I champion yeah that's
interesting and know what I understand
about success this is I've learned about
success you have to um I just want my
happiness depends on this my life
depends on this my existence depends on
this a Floyd I have to be champ of the
world the people have to love me I have
to fulfill my dream I being a great
fighter so we got we fought Otto before
our way out of the herd champ so many of
us died in jail in the streets right now
been doing a sister you know Garrett
Brownsville always been a ghetto Jewish
ghetto time I was telling about that yet
they wonder why do with their vision of
matter that the Jewish people had to
deal with the [ __ ] murder
incorporated
yes would yeah you should go get the
killers from Brownsville so yeah it's
like it's hard to cooperate this
hauntlywood [ __ ] fighting no no
listen
before it was uh it was just a dump
brown cells a dump
well all the city books all that dump
bad that's how it originated in this guy
I'm just Jewish gentleman by the name of
brown bought it and he didn't do nothing
with it but then they just became
grounds till after he died yeah it was a
dump process that started that dump
nobody listened
alright what 10% of the people graduate
from high school you know 10% of people
can pursue them if that graduate from
high school
don't go to college but it's a beautiful
place you got to see a champion you
gotta see this luxurious but now it is
now it is even in now the view from
Brownsville it's home you guys I can't
stop going here
I can style this when I was away from me
when I used to be Geico that summer time
or any time I had to go be away from me
when I got back home he was like oh you
found me it's home champ Brownsville we
love our brows they're all [ __ ] day
part my language to all the boys and
girls around the world
I apologize every time I see somebody
from Browns because I was watching them
you know the young lady Andy from them
Holly um hip-hop you know they showed
New York yeah in New York and she had
adopted daughter she had there was some
Brownsville and when I she told me shoot
some brown sighs my mind says she'd been
to hell I would just say that on my mind
I saw she's very attractive she's on
14th I said she must have been through
hell
being from brown so the meantime I have
the mentality I only like the fact that
I think that way he's mad not living
with yourself that you have this
mentality that you do Mike because
there's about marches you know imagine
that
yeah just chill just look we don't we
bought just don't [ __ ] with us yes pride
or we're we're pride or intake that's
what Ryder and pride or et people we
pride or until we survive survivors but
that's what makes the greatest business
people look at this man
Tyson ranch is the number one my
cannabis brand right now talked about in
the world let alone just in America when
I'm overseas which I'm a lot of times in
England people like yo you heard about
that Tyson ranch did you ever try that
Tyson ranch on my do that's my boy I'm
gonna get you some
you're the man suit fly you fly
everything going champ what what develop
this will cause this why do I dress nice
know I dress nice and stuff no I just
might look good I want to hide my filter
no brother no you always save IVA you
did it
you gotta be honest you gotta understand
how many of like new tell me kill the
cab tell me they tell me yo Jan you did
it you survived
you told me where these mom knew Tony
said yo Channing
I want this I seen ink and sing sing i
was up get boxing on a boxing trip i was
i was floored up in st. singing like
1991 I was in sing sing I seen Luke in
jail I was like oh [ __ ] he from the hood
used to come through with the big Dookie
ropes on you know saying he's to be
flying I'm saying he wasn't no no he was
a known hoodlum they different bad thing
year then you know Wild Bunch
no I'm saying shut out to stink Prospect
Plaza a buddy from Saratoga I be I'm
saying you know I mean up the hill
Atlantic Towers Bergen Street Pacific
shout-out but the whole thing Herkimer
Herkimer let's go champ
um you know my foot he's been through a
lot champ it fit through a lot of drop
never lose the trailer throw but I was
just that you don't say I was talking
new boots was what I was saying
I was talking to new and new said
Shannon you did the real [ __ ] he was
like yo I was banging getting streets
doing what I was doing but you had more
courage to go to the gym your [ __ ] look
weak to others but you had cuz look what
you did with your like he spent 33 years
in the joint upstate New York he home
now he told me he co Shannon you going
to the gym when I seen nuke in jail when
I seen you can gentlemen that boxing
trip I was like wow that's nuke from the
hood from the plaza I was like wow yeah
I'm saying
em he up here and any time I was doing
get me getting some trouble I was it was
in my mind
same-same that trip it was like some
scared straight [ __ ] we got to see the
whole dog walking around was Bob him Bob
jacks from Gleason he worked being some
[ __ ] real abarth friends yeah but
Scott's friends he used to take the trip
the big kids from New York City up to
fight the prisoner buddies the box
upstate New York Yankees because y'all
and I used to go up the end up those
memories
yeah flags I'm telling you champ and
I'll go up did I see a new Cup then I
was like he was my life it was Wow it
was wife's to pack bags of consumers
they listen man I just sell watermelons
Oh like the watermelon truck for Jules
Rimet juice got selling watermelons
iswhat from Jules sweet man melons over
there by myself
that was my pops of jewels and I just
sell the watermelons the sausage that
was me
I love you man you [ __ ] best ever my
boy ever so happy to see you champ
hey check this out right what would you
be like a view is just yourself
I'm neat champ this is the this this
this is you know BOTS they say Bob
Marley's a we show you who your true
self is huh and you know I've been
smoking since I got here
you fill me and this is a plan to save
my life because it's uh let me be me you
feel me
yeah and it helps me with the depression
you know it helps me with the aches and
pains I'm suffering from major aches and
pains that I haven't had an asthma
attack eight years I'm not making no
claim that I want to be sued my two
little kids to smoke cannabis you should
be I was medically prescribed cannabis
you're a medical example suffering from
depression
I was killers and um cannabis was good
for that stuff yeah I was medically
tried and I was at the end and it was
like I tried it on my own and was like
maybe I'm bugging I went to the doctor
never say listen that's the only thing
working for you brother
yeah take one one every hour on our for
the rest of your life let's go chat I
think you guys there's nobody better
than you guys to do something great and
give back to brown when I be incredible
unbelievable own it Scott her shout out
the sky hers he put it together you guys
I mean you you and my job raise up the
floor chuckles of letting chuckle the
bigger than we could ever be you know he
is so I'm fine it was just a man it was
just somebody I looked up to the two
Jocko he had all those people had Darryl
Dawkins dr. Gerald's big-time basketball
players coming to the hood Kareem
abdul-jabbar knows guys you know tell me
feel-good song somebody yes I do know
that and know who else'll the other lady
took with the arm melona well she's some
Browns or to really yeah Stephanie may
listen yeah she what's my grandmother
church-going don't know we're so proud
of them
I mean damn you know they're definite
they're very dignified they made it with
their dignity and saw priced occasion we
made it without ferocity and no
education and stuff like that you know
Sheehan what else he got rolling these
days yeah Kenneth did channel got us
into the boxing because got a promoted
fighter either hit-and-miss guys left my
brother's never know he wasn't the money
every now money whether do these rich
Carthaginians the giveaway and he called
me if I love them so much my boy I
always did like a cold I don't know what
I'm doing put out I'm just hustling you
know and I use that word but you know a
proper way I was doing the elite I don't
champ don't believe in no crime yeah
ain't gonna nobody's prison if I can
help you know I'm Browns they if they
want to straighten their life they know
that to go that route yeah they know the
old life it's been crime my old guard
has been crying yeah and if you wasn't a
criminal I hated your cut
I don't know crime chat but champagne
with that you know cuz I'm too smart to
be someone's prison you phone me yeah
and with that being said I'm just you
know I'm are here making deals I was
fortunate to have a great mentor my life
has Scott Hirsch hmm he's done a lot for
me yeah there's no good way people like
you I love white people I love everybody
don't share you know me well know when I
was crazy know me [ __ ] white people
love you dad [ __ ] I let everybody
that's what me about the chance I'm
colorblind
like you blah y'all Mexican I believe me
too
you know I travel a lot a bit fortune
and that's what I give thanks to him so
much to be as he was a part of my puzzle
to get in my life to where it is
traveling the world means so many people
I went as a kid I tried with the polling
now I travel to Russia I travel to
Ireland I went to these different
countries why was Justin Brown I was
just saying the tile was that was just
from picking a band I was just sleeping
on the D train
you feel me I was
just a wink a park you know and now here
I am and polling Ireland and and I got
out the hood and it gave me inspiration
you fill me and I was able to do so lose
some of my life you know me and Here I
am today I started this brand let's go
champ the websites up Shannon Briggs
calm and I'm hustling now on key I want
my like I said earlier my goal is to put
something away from my family and once I
do that my son Chan you know my daughter
Momo fat my son Kayden once I got them
straight and it's whatever you know I
might be like a [ __ ] you know but now
I'm never going for the clip I'm always
going you know what the bucket and chill
not you know what it is I'm gonna keep
it real with you chairman this is what
mike has to understand I know he will
relate let's go champ this this whole
trying to play my life with the with
this macho slogan movement movement gave
me purpose you feel me
yeah because every day when I look at my
inbox and I see a kid a mother or father
or daughter saying chant thank you for
inspiration yeah I was suicidal when I
heard your story and you know it's just
it's a [ __ ] champ you feel me when I
meet brothers like you know I was
walking Austria I met a brother named
Jimmy Jimmy Jam you know from the
originals and he just we kicked it I
like this vibe but that's what let's go
chanted yeah that's what this viral is
going right being myself you know he
asked me who would I be this allowed me
to be this when I took my first hit and
I started crying and I cut my hair off
and I started saying let's go champ
let me just - Here I am sitting with
Mike Tyson and yourself look at you
champ I'm so happy to be here this [ __ ]
gone hopefully take me to another level
you feel me of being more people inspire
more people around the world to say you
know what Shannon and give up so I ain't
giving up my can't give up I ain't
giving up you feel me thank you that's
what it's about
I'll only cost was so proud that I was
from Brownsville yeah he just said
you're the go-to the fighter cuz he said
um they're really tough the people
but really tough people they just needed
is misguided that's why we go open the
jump gonna break chores everywhere
around the world was so proud when he
had me that was some browsers and he
always told me I should be proud to be
from Nicholas look what it does for you
guys
he's always though he gave me someone
and I saw it they became he told me he
has taught me that he proud of where I
was from
[Music]
you guys are incredible man both you
guys are incredible dudes I swallowed my
spirits huh that's why I like white
people yeah because Teddy needs I'm
saying he gave me a shot ma gave me a
shot but more first and foremost might
gave me a sight like Molly and then
Scott is a Jewish brother from Hollywood
Florida but we got we brothers ain't
white an anabolic an we brothers you
feel me so that's why I'd be like yo you
know that race [ __ ] I get mad when I see
racism because I got brothers that's why
here
they love me like I'm they brother you
feel me I got brothers that's Asian they
love me that a chill for me
I've been trying I'll travel the world
let it do from Afghanistan he was the
doorman hmm he said I can't believe I
met you I said come on champ it's all
good
you started kicking it I said man you
could give me some trees he said come on
Channel I can't believe you said that
I got you went to his house brother his
whole family from Afghanistan they
couldn't believe it I was in the hood in
Germany in the so-called projects in
Germany and Afghanistan they called
everybody Dave his loving me it was like
we can't believe it
so when people ask me where you from I'm
from everywhere cuz I'm the champ
that's what custom made me think that
custom motto right he made me believe
being a heavyweight champ with
everything
yes made me I had to do that there's no
way I was gonna fail you imagine that
this old Italian guy did something to me
Jamie but you know Richie believes a
peep game he was born in 1908 so it's a
peep game my life changed in 1908 if I
was even when my grandparents probably
would live
I feel about Julie oh yeah she'll
Ferelden when it was born my rifle my
life has changed in 1908 before I was 57
years 56 57 years before was born my
life was changed there's so many pieces
don't you no matter how many times we
walked past or you pass my mother or no
my mother what she knew you or your
mother
Oh think about how you might tell you
something else but I'm we got my
confidently thing I'm talking about I'm
talking about ten thousand years ago
wherever you who were you ten thousand
years ago ten thousand in a long time
probably another word more than trillion
I think it's reset a few times who
nanny's had to start over maybe three or
four times so we don't really know you
don't say everything but I still evil
wants us to know things we we want to be
smart so YouTube is so [ __ ] people in
life we want to know something
yeah well we want to be the one to know
and no one else knows do you want to be
teachers we want to be to know to have
the knowledge you want to be the watches
you know I want to be with people that
smart now excuse me I want to be with
people that's what the knowledge like I
want to be with people like yourself I
don't want to be with people anymore I
used to like understand what you say
you're given a knowledge but I'm in
search now to be with someone who has
the knowledge or more that I can gain
from I could teach me yet I'm saying cuz
I'm try to give it you know will you
make it out the hood oh let me just say
this channel and you can really possibly
relate will you make it out the hood
you'll be going back and giving back to
everybody
cuz you the one that made it when I was
doing this when I was making it I felt
obligated to help my friends out the
hood you feel him saying and then when I
have it she was different you feel I'm
saying I couldn't
and people talked on the phone I'm
saying what you want to surround
yourself with people you can learn from
them
yeah I don't want to be around people
that's gonna take from me no more
because I can't always I can't go toward
um when I need I couldn't you know so
I'm so little Dolan my life is my family
if you add a close few friends around me
if you ain't that doesn't fill me such a
beautiful personally the baby but you're
gonna really ran in life that um it's
gonna sometime in your life you know
gods allow you to continue to live that
giving us everything so if you're gonna
get so much power from giving you won't
be able to have enough you want to give
everything away your so much power and
giving and then when you give some month
in you [ __ ] feel so bad you gave so
much no no no you feel better you don't
got more to give you know that you the
[ __ ] will you broke they didn't
laugh at you when you ain't got it no
more I just experienced that chance well
you could give give give and when you
ain't got to give to learn more they
know I check this out - this is really
interesting know why I bother to you you
you think you're important your ego is
you're either that's why you think
you're somebody you don't know that you
you know where nobody it could listen to
you thinking you imagine how big my ego
has I can imagine but I'm somebody only
to help my family now my focus is on
help I'm so I still champion all day
every day I give everything I got it's a
whole list of people because I've been
here so but I got it stop being so
selfless with others and focus on the
people the core people this is what I do
I think here my wife she does have money
but the rest goes through the world
because when I ain't gotta get to give
to him guess what they laugh at you
brother
see I got evicted from the towers and
when I got evicted
people live and when you homeless people
laugh at you my mother was a
can woman she she was a nurse in
addition we lost it on Scotland drugs
heroin made a crack you know me so
people laugh people turn on you you feel
it I'm saying so that's why you know me
I have that hope people will turn on you
and it's always happen check this out
right you still want to be somebody I
don't know what that no no you you want
to put a look up to you know it's one of
make it for my family really that's what
you want I said yeah I feel you want I
see you want your family to look up to
you think what that is great I you know
I was born I'm a Sagittarius I'm going
to some before they're tough but the
people my friend we don't live long
that's not true beliefs fact no and we
don't live long and then my family
people don't live long let's go champ
thank you Mike but I said I'd to say the
people my friend the menus you don't
live that whatever you believe him hard
it's the truth hard I'm changing that
but I lived a hard life young life - I
live heart you feel me I miss suffering
depression since I was 13 years old not
before that
I got [ __ ] in my side but sadness you
know we've seen your mom die drugs yeah
my dad died prison ain't no pity party I
told y'all [ __ ] pity Birds
well you're sick aren't you I got scars
yeah and like you said were you trying
to fill up the holes and [ __ ] is not
gonna happen
sex with drinkin and whatever whatever
so yeah I can't go that route that fat
as a [ __ ] pig you should have seen me
I couldn't see my [ __ ] joint
I was looking crazy you feel that was so
bad I mean but me I always think I do
what you do I always want people to feel
sorry for me but I know I'm a fat [ __ ]
for honey but I know i'ma lose this way
you know I mean I know I'm gonna lose
this was it I watched every burger there
and I watched my heart but I'll lead the
way
I'm a savage I look up to people my life
is nothing I don't love myself I love
the people I saw earlier I saw the rant
I [ __ ] fell in love no listen um I
was I was 12 years old so sex is not
effects we're looking for we're looking
for love it's sex and love addicts we
equate sex with laws yeah yeah listen
listen we're big losses in a war we're
gonna lose yeah I fell in love with my
dick my dick was my conscience for a joy
I'm always conscious about now that I'm
living what I believe is the the proper
life I'm always conscious of my actions
with women what do you do yes you know I
know what not to do hmm that should do
the contrary yes I guess my experience
in life I'm 53 years old you know I do
you know I did that before I was at this
situation before where I could say hey
I'm going this way but I went that way I
know it's gonna happen I never tried
doing this way before so I'm trying this
way now I know it's gonna happen the
other day I might fall in love with this
woman and they [ __ ] my family can't
imagine that I'm so dick conscious I'm
like my dick tells me I'm in love this
is great [ __ ] don't leave this [ __ ]
not my mind not my heart my dick tells
me that and I listen to a [ __ ] idiot
without a brain
he just wants pleasure you don't even
wanna play don't care if he catches the
disease anything it has to be done it
has to be done I have to get that nut
I'll give him Kitchen Aid I don't care
what it is he's after that nut sandwich
yeah a lot of guys feel [ __ ] crazy is
let's go champ
I am listen that's my mother and father
was my father
yeah Wow this [ __ ] show
best ever huh well [ __ ] it before we
wrap this thing up man is there anything
you wanna shout yeah do you want people
to know about your let's go let's go
chair let's go champ for the people you
feel me pick yourself up if you need to
watch the show good find somebody you
know I'm saying to look up to inter you
know hey Bianca if tell the world I'm
afraid you are
yeah I'm afraid I'm afraid of failure
I'm afraid to leave my family in despair
and to have to beat women because I have
not went hungry
I went cold at night and I don't want to
leave my kids like that that's all and I
partied a lot I did all my thing bought
cars did all that boiling [ __ ]
and then you look back as most athletes
do like that yeah I wish I had that now
so now what I do
I'm working hard champ emotional heart
like mine said I'll call my couple you
might listen I got this deal for you
you're coming town that's what I do
I'm moving the shaken champ I'm doing
everything positive I'm saying let's go
champ
I'm the fear champ you right brother I'm
in fear to leave my family behind for
what I see in this earth to leave them
at despair financially now money can
come and go you feel me I just don't
leave my family
listen I'm always afraid I don't even
know what I'm afraid of you know I'm not
afraid of my my wife my wife is very
savvy she can take care of the kids she
can do whatever you know I know I guess
no I'm from my experience with women and
my mother and house crew and stuff they
were do we are germs and we're gonna
survive you know I guess I always think
about that what are we as people who are
we what are we and I try to think and
then I only then I come to
that we're [ __ ] germs you know some
people we go next - I'm not talking my
black I misspoke my human beand yes look
we got these sick [ __ ] in China
dare us yesterday change this is this
way
these Chinese sick [ __ ] no
that's you [ __ ]
we're done we're you know Nicole be look
what happened the Kobe he was here and
then he's gone so everyday you gotta
love your life and that you got breath
you alive you flag do tooi
[ __ ] fly [ __ ] all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
material [ __ ] that's [ __ ] that's
nothing you tell me you can have all
that shouldn't be miserable
you tell me right that was me - cuz I
was chasing but you said that in the
next high I had a girl that was my girls
I'm from Browns it comes from lack of
self-love we actually don't love
ourselves around food how could we Wow
and then um every woman ID has
characteristics of my mother even my
wife we can't get away from them we
can't leave them we can't get we try to
get away like I was talking like that
brah
how am I going hey I gotta go
they know me without me that I've been
born 20 years before them and they know
me they know who I am they know what's
in my heart they know us in my mind they
know what I think just because I'm from
that neighborhood they know what I think
I guess I'm fighting to look for
you feel I'm saying I'm just looking for
a brighter day and enjoy my kids
why are you here and I'm here my
daughter Moffat
techno huh cuz she's growing so fast you
know my boy is growing up so are they
growing so fast before that I'd be old
and washed up so I gotta just keep
laughing all day being silly having fun
with dumb and just leave him a nest egg
and you know a certain search app we
champions brother we gonna open up the
Brownsville boxing Academy are we gonna
do the film there Browns will never end
never will keep him right my mother died
and my mother was education like three
and she really thought that we weren't
gonna make it without her levy would
never succeed however brother that's a
surgeon I was you know I had my sister
that died from drugs but she was smart
she was smarter than everybody what is
smart be what a good people get are
scumbags don't get addicted hmm
you know they have focus in life the
people who we consider it bad but their
focus they have things to do that's
funny we consider them bad because we
don't they don't allow us to get into
their world they do focus you know
anybody we've got them falls with we
look at them as being bad mm-hmm they
don't pay attention they don't notice us
we think they [ __ ] up people doing
incredible work having you here thank
you champ thank you chap my love you
guys forever we love you man Shannon
Briggs calm all right everybody well man
what a powerful episode hmm Brownsville
Kings man found fool listen man I'm
Jewish you guys are killing everybody
King murder
Murder Inc is missing right I know I'm
we are able from but listen I'm we try
to hold that reputation you know they
were tough guys Murder Inc you know
ain't that some [ __ ] these Jewish guys
now we gotta lift that reputation that
we had the black guys and the Puerto
Rican now listen that we wanted to hold
that reputation of don't stop
you got braids you in buggin out like
that we don't open up a gym he's gonna
do it look at him being from Brownsville
well from two of the toughest dudes I've
ever met thank you guys for watching
this episode of hot boxing hey listen
wait you said that our toughness is not
from us fight as the girls absorbing
punishment yeah in life how do we make
out of all my friends are dead or
something
you know majora faith 75% of them are
dead either you know from the lie for
some dope yeah yes life yeah life's man
this been hit hard by life why am i with
these drama in this [ __ ] place if I
might shoot me from up along this and I
might diet people jealous well I might
thing that I'll always Miami Oh should I
got a surfeit because I'm one of these
guys you're a light but yeah let's give
those kidneys I brought you a Browns
real shirt you higher look at that chat
huh huh huh let's dough let's go chat
that's still I feel like I'll give them
a big brother gift look look I'm like a
little I want to get out the box they
looking at it it just came home I'm like
look um plug yes think I'm fun [ __ ]
Brownsville look
[Laughter]
thank you thank you brother
thanks everybody for watching this
awesome episode of hotbox
yeah all right Mike thank you my brother
No thank you man I'm your son I'm just
grateful for the universe I can't leave
that had the life that I had yeah
I'm from I'm from the Sun I'm from my
god I can't believe the life that I had
oh [ __ ] I can't believe I'm full of that
I slept with some [ __ ] incredible
people
[ __ ] you're showing people the way man
no he saw my path days so I came when
they were done for me II know you when
the bed no me I was chasing him trying
to be Mike I was trying to get him
saying Mickey cuz of you yeah so it
wasn't no you oh but don't me my
wouldn't have my wife and kids living in
a Florida and a beautiful home I was
homeless Chad real talk
I was living in my aunts basement for a
while I went to relative's house and
they couldn't keep me some time so
because of you I got a house in Florida
with a beautiful life and family you
feel me
cuz I was chasing you was a blueprint
something to look up to and that's what
I'll try to tell kids I ain't the grace
Moore
speaker I got to try getting no
endorsements just let's go champ
but I always tell always tell kids champ
find somebody to look up to admire
yourself after them Patti Kobe yeah yeah
I'd say wow the Anthony Joshua might tie
somebody in there good attributes
everybody is to read before they had
them the phones and the computers not
[ __ ] we had to read so I just go to the
cyclopædia read about old fighters and
different [ __ ] like that and watch two
books I had to go listen I had to go to
the right he Manning on the library
looking up I had the first had to do
this and looking at what what library
this book was I'm reading about some
Jews and some time then Jewish um
libraries and ain't letting the books go
they see my black library to read about
people yeah me too we gave my Barry
Browns your library ice to go to to read
about boxes you know all day I'd be
there all [ __ ] day to open to the
clothes I swear to God on my dead mother
I should do the same thing cuz the read
about boxing then I met people in
Flatbush and they and I lived in
Flatbush I lived right down a she lived
no 18:18 Newkirk your sister lives right
across the street
Jackie lived right across the street do
you understand what I'm trying to tell
you this she could go on forever because
I wanted to move in the Flatbush I lived
in 1818 neutral his system is right
across the street Jackie what you feel
me I can't make this [ __ ] up I can't
make this [ __ ] out I was following I was
[ __ ] you got a fine I tell the kids find
somebody latch on to them in a positive
way and make make a life for yourself if
you're saying well there's Kobe recipes
to Kobe is LeBron is my Tyson is Wilder
it's a famous rapper in a positive way
do [ __ ] positive or you'll go to jail
the prison is full and they making them
every brand new day so let's go check
and listen this is really interesting
that he said that and sometimes I'm we
go to prison and we become awakened
so prison is not always a bad thing
it looks bad it appears bad but look
Malcolm if people go there and they
become enlightened so it's just a
Bigfoot is too few many Malcolm X's yeah
so so many millions of black brothers
incarcerated white brothers incarcerated
Hispanic brothers incarcerated to get
one I'm saying we got to change that
[ __ ] up
I just think why do you think prison is
a way of um people grow up in prison I
think people grow up in prayer advice
because I know I was institutionalized
I was institutionalized and generally
came in my life he came in visited this
[ __ ] prison this children hidden in
my life change in your madness and so I
went from Spofford then I had to go
upstate to do time and then I go upstair
me Bobby Stewart he's acting fired up
I'm 12 years old 13 year I'm 13 at the
time and they stuff teaching me out of
sight and so something happens I handle
what a jab or something and I think as
nose break and he has to the two black
eyes right and then he's looking mad so
I'm thinking mad at me good and he's mad
because his wife his upset says I can't
box with you know most of my wife is mad
something to that effect he said don't
worry I'm gonna take you to this
gentleman custom Arlen he's gonna take
it to the next level and what happened
well when I first went there I was
thinking I saw housing I found my raw up
these white [ __ ] notice no I'm
serious I was gonna rob these [ __ ]
stupid white [ __ ] or let some
got a kid from institutionalized [ __ ]
come in the house and take care of him
and take him as a family [ __ ] these
stupid white [ __ ] they get in it
and I fell in love with him he gave me
he made me fall a wolf [ __ ] [ __ ]
wooly Bennie fall in love with myself
the words they never happened to my life
but the best thing to it made me follow
that with Delta nothing
okay let's finish this I'm sorry
inside this is over this [ __ ] was over
like it's all good no Mike [ __ ]
that's beautiful note well thank you
guys both for sharing your knowledge
with me and Shannon great calm let's go
champ let's go Jack head over to hotbox
in podcast.com for all the episodes all
the latest [ __ ] sign up for a newsletter
etc etc got merch coming hey until next
time Tom Abbott Britain I might dies in
an under trap Shannon - tanning let's go
[Music]
[Music]